I want to show you how to color a
transparent piece of plastic without
adding anything to it no dyes paint
nothing except holes but first we have
to talk about light most people know
that it's a form of electromagnetic
radiation but have you ever stopped to
think about how strange that is I mean
light is a combination of electric and
magnetic fields electric fields like the
ones that make these balloons repel and
magnetic fields like the ones that make
these magnets attract but how can you
strip off the electric field from around
charge and the magnetic field from
around a magnet and combine those fields
together so that they can propagate out
through space at the speed of light well
the key is the electric and magnetic
fields need to be continuously changing
and this is usually accomplished by
wiggling some electrons that creates
these oscillating electric and magnetic
fields that propagate out through space
as an electromagnetic wave so how big is
a wavelength of visible light well take
a ruler and have a look at a millimeter
imagine magnifying that millimeter so
it's the size of a meter now divide that
millimeter into a thousand or in other
words take a millimeter of a millimeter
and then divide that in half and that is
the wavelength of green light now
granted that is tiny but my point is
it's not that tiny and Nature has
actually figured out a way to take
advantage of the size of light have a
look at this blue morpho butterfly
what's really neat about the Blue Morpho
is yeah it has this really blue
iridescent shiny wings but nobody
actually really knows why they want to
attract a mate or something the leading
theory that I've read is actually to let
predators know like birds that hey you
know me I'm really fast and I move
really well through the jungle don't
even bother
that beautiful iridescent blue color
isn't created by a pigment no the color
of the Blue Morpho is created by the
structure of its scales if we were to
zoom in on this butterfly we'd see all
these little sort of gratings and holes
within these gratings that trap the
light and reflect out this blue
if we just kind of look at it direct
into the light so we've taken away the
light that was bouncing off the front
yeah you can see that the blue goes away
and all you can see is really the
background in fact that's because the
the wings are almost transparent without
that light being able to reflect off of
it you don't get any blue scientists
like Clint are trying to create similar
structures to be used as security
devices on banknotes bank cards and
tickets what you're looking at is just a
thin transparent piece of plastic and
we've punched little tiny holes the
holes are about 100 nanometers deep and
100 nanometers in diameter each little
image that you see on there has about
500 million holes punched into it and
those holes create a three-dimensional
kind of grading that allow for they like
to reflect and reflect out I create
those brilliant colors the color is
created in a similar way to the color of
a soap film if you carefully study a
soap bubble you'll find that you can't
see all the colors of the rainbow in the
soap film all you can really see is cyan
magenta and yellow well the reason for
that is what the soap film is doing is
it's actually removing colors from the
light so the full spectrum of visible
light hits the film but depending on the
thickness of the soap layer certain
colors are removed and so what we see is
the spectrum of visible light - a color
that's been taken out so for example in
order to see magenta what we need to do
is remove the green light from the
spectrum the light that bounces off the
front surface will interfere with the
light that bounces off the back surface
of that soap film so when it comes out
any light that's about 500 nanometers is
removed from the light and what we see
is a mixture of the rest of the spectrum
so longer wavelengths than green and
shorter wavelengths in green together
they make that beautiful magenta color
so what you want to look for is
structures that are similar but can be
compatible with many fashion processes
where for example a printing press
process where you have a big roll of
substrate it's going to come along and
you've got a big process just going to
stamp down and punch in those structures
but
you create like nano scale structures
and punch them into a material isn't
that nearly impossible no no no but it
sounds like you're gonna manufacture
these tiny things and then they're not
going to break off when you're stamping
them no and that's you know one thing
everybody thinks is you know oh well
they're small and small things are
fragile that's that's just not the case
one of the reasons that our our
structures can be strong is that it has
a low aspect ratio which means that the
height to width is low so a high aspect
ratio let's say might be 10 to 1 so it's
long and skinny and that is a weak
structure ideally you want a structure
that's one to one or maybe one to two
and what we do is we create structures
that are 200 nanometers wide and maybe 3
400 nanometers tall and we use that to
punch in and those structures are really
really strong for the moment Australian
bills are made of plastic and they have
this little transparent window in them
stop counterfeiters but perhaps in
future they'll have hundreds of millions
of tiny nano scale holes instead the
Australians were the ones that you know
invented the polymer banknote so would
you be looking to get your technology in
there have you been in dialogue with the
Australians I cannot comment on that